we've got to be a little careful about
this neutral language because not some
things can't be neutral the great
example is you call the girl she or you
call the girl he and
that
that is not neutral there's no neutral
ground you're making a moral claim there
and there's this idea it's lexarandi lex
credenti the way that we worship the way
that we
and really the french yeah you know it's
classic arabic so the way that we
worship affects the way that we believe
and so these people who have been just
trained in these rituals of
of leftism liberalism whatever you want
to call it they're trained in it they
know that it's making them miserable the
practices that have defined their lives
have ruined their lives they'll even
admit it in a way in the paper but they
can't change the belief that is the
power because we have bot we are bodies
in many ways and so the things that we
do every single day our behaviors every
day are going to affect the way that we
believe it's why we rarely succeed
actually when we make totally rational
arguments for why our way is better than
their way it doesn't matter they gotta
do it